[Musique]
c'est une ville que je connais
une chanson que je
[Musique]
ais chant sur le trottoir
c'est savoir poussière brûlé
ces ongles sur le blindé ils l'ont battu
à mort il a froid il a faim j'entends
mal son cœur
de n'importe quelle couleur
au lavabo Cagnes
colonioso
il vivait avec des mots pour passer sous
[Musique]
le montant des couteaux
il jouait de la dérision
piment mais ces chansons maudites on les
connaît par cœur
la musique parfois à des accords majeurs
qui font rire les enfants mais pas les
dictateurs
de n'importe quel pays de n'importe
quelle couleur
la musique est un cri qui vient de
l'intérieur
[Musique]
ça dépend de ton attitude c'est son
temps de solitude
[Musique]
piano
il y a des bottes sur mon tempo
au-dessous du volcan de l'entange de
l'entendre j'entends pas son cœur
la musique
popcorina
qui font grincer les dents du Grand
libérateur
de n'importe quel pays de n'importe
quelle couleur
la musique est un cri qui vient de
l'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est une ville que je connais
une chanson que je chantais une chanson
qui nous ressemble pour des cahiers
[Musique]
c'est la voix demandait là
nous tempo docteur
chanter la foule avec tes mots qui
roulent les fonds Mac son cœur
la musique est un cric qui vient de la
période
pour le moment
[Musique]
la musique est un cri qui vient de
l'intérieur
on a pas montagnes
la musique est un cri qui vient de
l'intérieur
[Musique]